well it was a moment of defiance that
went viral a ukrainian border guard not
so politely refusing to surrender snake
island to a russian warship using some
very colorful language
a new postage stamp depicts the guard
and the ship the moskva now ukraine
claims to have sunk the vessel and the
stamp has become a collector's item
an air of defiance
ukrainians are queueing up to buy a
stamp that they now believe depicts
russian defeat
this is the symbol of ukraine's victory
which is yet to come
the recently released stamp portrays the
moment when a ukrainian soldier told the
moskva ship to go f itself when the
russian forces on board tried to capture
ukraine's snake island in the black sea
its release feels somewhat prophetic to
ukrainians now as the very ship depicted
here is the one that came under fire
this week
president vladimir zelensky unveiled the
design on his instagram page with the
message the russian warship always has
only one direction
russians expected ukraine to surrender
in two to three days i think you're
asked why it's so popular because that's
the symbol of why ukraine does not
surrender does not surrender it will win
and you know it's 51st day of the war
and it shows that i think the closer
will be winning
this russian setback is something that
instills hope in the people of ukraine
hope that their country
will survive
you